welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and after a pretty
slow season three the ending of The
Handmaid's Tale has arguably dropped one
of its most shocking cliffhangers
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the finale as well as where the
show could be heading down the line
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you don't want to know anything about
the final episode then I highly
recommend that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for quick in this video now let's
get into my ending explain breakdown of
The Handmaid's Tale season 3 so season 3
has pretty much been about June having
enough with life in Gilead and after
seen many characters die over the last
13 episodes she decided that enough was
enough and then it was time to break the
children out of the country alongside
commander Lawrence things throughout the
season seemed to be going June's way and
it could be argued that she's had quite
an easy ride this time around well in
comparison to other seasons anyway a lot
of her plans have fallen into place
throughout the series and you might even
be able to throw a Handmaid's Tale party
to celebrate yeah maybe not her main
mission this time was to get 52 children
free from gilead and the finale opened
with a flashback of her from when she
was first captured seeing many mothers
including herself losing their children
this of course mirrors her plan which is
to take the children back and you really
get the feeling that this is a
completely personal mission for Jude who
finally wishes to right all the wrongs
they have been dealt to her and the
women of gill yet this is all about girl
power and she even goes past commander
Lawrence refusing to quit the plan when
things look like they could go awry
whilst things do have a rather positive
end that doesn't mean that it's all
smooth sailing for all the characters
and in this episode we also pick up with
Serena who after the last episode was
exposed by her husband for her war
crimes
Serena is arrested and it finally looks
like we can dance in the streets singing
ding dong the witch is dead Jun doesn't
have time to celebrate though and after
Lawrence tells her that he won't escape
due to the fact that he will probably
arrested as a war criminal as well he
decides to remain behind and let her go
and be the Moses of her own story
alongside the martha's at June and the
children head towards the airport
through the woods and if you're not
having an anxiety attack by this point
then don't worry because the show still
has some surprises up its sleeve at the
airport the police show up and June sees
no other option but to distract the
authorities and to sacrifice herself
which allows the children time to escape
to Canada and to reunite with Moyra
Emily and Luke which is a really
triumphant moment June literally isn't
out of the woods yet though and she's
shot during the final few scenes of the
season we close with June in the forest
being carried away as handmaids gather
around her she begins to dream of Hannah
and Luke and in the final look we see
her close their eyes smiling as she
thinks of all the lives that she's saved
this ends the show on a huge cliffhanger
and there's actually a lot of
speculation on the internet as to
whether June is alive or dead there are
a couple of hints that this may have
been her final episode throughout with
the character pretty much becoming a
martyr in the storyline personally I
actually think that the showrunners may
kill the character off and potentially
focus on a new main character that is
sort of inspired by June's heroic acts
The Handmaid's Tale has never been one
for cliches and with there being a
slightly negative feeling towards the
3rd season and it's repetitive outlook I
think this would be the perfect
opportunity to veer off into uncharted
territory with a new perspective and
someone that could really go on a huge
arc in the upcoming seasons June is no
longer afraid of the consequences of
their actions and she's almost above
those in gilead flat-out disobeying them
at the majority of times which I think
completes her awk however if they do
decide to keep her alive then I can see
her possibly getting out of gilead in
the next season and our focus shifting
to a new character or potentially
showing her work on the outside as she
tries to bring down Gilead from Canada
either way there's a lot of New
Directions that the show could take and
I'm excited to see where it heads in the
future but what did I think of the
season overall well I think on the whole
this has probably been the weakest of
all three seasons with the show bearing
off into meandering territory and
several occasions
after feeling slightly underwhelming
until probably the latter part of the
season that just weren't the huge gut
punches that we've become accustomed to
and this on the whole left me feeling
slightly disappointed in the overall run
I'm not saying it's time to completely
close the book on the characters but I
do think that there is an opportunity
here to discover new and exciting venues
and hopefully going forward the show
takes it whilst it wasn't terrible
season 3 didn't live up to the highs and
lows of the prior series and that's why
it gets seven out of ten
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the finale of The Handmaid's Tale do
you think June is alive or dead and what
do you hope to see in the future comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and make
sure you check out my breakdown of the
ending of euphoria which would be linked
after this in it I give my thoughts on
the finale so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more if
you want to come talk to me about movies
TV shows games and comic books then you
can follow me on Twitter a definition
whitey it's the best way to get in touch
with me and it's the perfect place to
suggest new videos and content so
hopefully I see you over there after
this I also just want to let you know
that we're giving away a free copy of
John wick 3 on blu-ray and all you have
to do to be in with the chance of
winning is to like this video make sure
that you subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on The Handmaid's
Tale in the comments section below
the winner will be chosen at random on
September the 10th and the blu-ray will
be shipped out from the end whoever gets
surprised it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]